the UK side knows what a Hong Kong is no
longer under its colonial rule and the
Hong Kong has returned to China and is
now part of China
y'okay has no sovereignty jurisdiction
or rights of supervision over Hong Kong
after handover
however the UK government keeps making
irresponsible remarks on Hong Kong
affairs through a so-called six monthly
report on Hong Kong make unwarranted
accuse Asians against the national
security law or Hong Kong SAR and even
talks about changing the arrangements
for British national overseas passport
holders in Hong Kong
this moves constituted a gross
interference in China's internal affairs
an openly trample on the basic norms
governing international relations the
Chinese side has lost solemn
representation to the UK sign to express
its grave concern and the strong
opposition I want to emphasize that Hong
Kong is a part of China Hong Kong
affairs a China's internal affairs and
Brooke no external interference one
important task of the national security
law for Hong Kong SAR
is to prevent suppress and punish
collusion with a foreign country always
external elements to endanger national
security no one should underestimate the
firm determination of China to safeguard
sovereignty security and development
injuries
attempts to disrupt or obstruct the
implementation of the national security
law for Hong Kong as they are will be
met with the strong opposition of 1.4
billion Chinese people all this attempts
are doomed to failure